One challenge when using arrays is that the length is fixed.
So let's say that you need to collect some numbers and
you don't quite know how many, you're going to have to make
an array that's large enough to hold them all. But then
you may have fewer numbers in the array. Then it can
hold. We say such an array is partially filled, just like
this beaker over here. You wouldn't want it to be filled
up all the way to the rim. And in this situation you
need to keep track of two things. You need,
the overall length of the array. So here I'll
assume I'll never have more than 1000 numbers. I
allocate my array to have this length and then I
keep a companion variable that I call the size
that tells me how many elements I currently have.
Right now, I don't have any. Whenever I need
to insert a new element, I execute this code here.
I move the new value into values in
bracket size, and then I increment the size. For
example, to insert the very first element, size
is 0, values bracket 0, is now initialized, and
the size becomes 1. The next time, values of 1 Gets filled and so on. Now what
happens if I fill up the array with a thousand values and then want to add the
thousand and first. Let's have a look at that situation.
So here I have my partially filled beaker. I fill in
more and more, and eventually when it gets full, what
choice do I have? I have to get a bigger one
and pour everything into that. It's the same with partially
filled arrays. So, here's my array. It's almost full. Now it's
completely full. I'd like to add another element. So, I'll
get myself an array that's twice as long, copy over all
the values, and now I can forget about
the old array, and insert my next element over
here. Of course, one can program that by hand,
but as it happens There's a library function that
does the work for us. Here it is. The
copyOf function takes an array and then the desired
length of the larger array. It then makes the
larger array and copies the original one in there,
returns the large array, and we just capture it here again. So that's what
you'd have to do if you're ever faced with a situation Where you want
to collect an arbitrary number of values. It's that kind of thing that makes
you appreciate the array lists where you
never have to worry about growing an array.